this is my first Star Wars Celebration
and I get to be here not just a fan but
on this stage for the first time while
we introduce rogue one which is the
first Star Wars standalone story
why Gareth Edwards and it's bit
embarrassing because he's sitting here
but why did you choose him to direct
this film thank you no words yeah no
seriously it's funny when the cameras
were swinging around I saw our DP Greg
where are you right there and Greg and
Gareth were actually amazing to watch
because Gareth made this decision based
on a style that he uses with the movies
he makes where he puts the camera on his
shoulder for just about every shot and
that really sort of gave us the sense of
what the style of the movie might be and
more importantly it's a style that is
unlike any other Star Wars movie and the
whole time we were making the movie I
would often walk onto the set I feel
like where's Gareth and then I see him
this huge camera on his shoulder off in
the middle of the shot doing another
angle finding some incredible way to
immerse us inside the movie and I think
that's what is so amazing about his
style is this is going to be an
incredibly immersive experience when you
see rogue one it seems like it really
enhances our experience of the world and
Gareth please can you tell me about your
personal connection to Star Wars and
what it means you obviously not just
professionally but personally to be a
fan and direct this film I mean I think
I'm probably a lot like everybody in
this audience in that I watched a new
hope every day growing up until that be
IMAX tape was completely worn out and if
you told me that one day I get to direct
this film I'd never believed you like I
sort of think in some parallel world I'm
out there watching me on stage very
jealous saying shut up you idiot I
should be doing that and it's just been
the most insane mode
surreal experience you could ever have
everyday just when you think you've had
the craziest day in your life the next
day tops it was there a particularly
memorable day for you there's a million
on I guess on one occasion we were
filming I was with felicity and we're in
the middle of a shot and someone just
nudged me and said pointing to this guy
in the corner I said do you want to meet
Luke Skywalker and I looked over there
was Mark Hamill and and I went over to
him and he was wearing a Godzilla
t-shirt which which is the film I made
before and and I was like you know when
you got to someone you're so much in all
of them I don't know what he said to him
I was trying to be articulate and
intelligent and I don't know what came
out and he was being really sweet and
complimentary and all I was thinking as
he was talking to me was just looking at
my peripheral vision go ahead please
lord someone be taking a photograph of
this no one's gonna believe that I met
Luke Skywalker and the problem with this
film is you can't talk about it you
can't tell your friends you can't tell
your family anything and all I wanted to
do was go home and go look at everyone's
like how was working like yes alright
fine internally met Luke Skywalker how
was your day I was a supermarket right
yeah and there's all sorts of new
environments as well absolutely
Gareth please can you tell us a bit
about those yeah my favourite one
probably because it meant we got to go
to the Maldives is a planet which was
like a trick that you played on us
sometimes you gotta take one sometimes
you got to take one for the team
having year and it's a planet called
scarab and and we were going for realism
throughout the film and so we tried to
go to relocations just so happened it
was set in this paradise world we had to
go to Paradise to film it it was a nice
time yeah it's a tough place and then
it's funny because all the guys you see
in this picture they're all this is the
Maldivian army and as we're filming it
we're thinking guys so cool imagine
being these guys and they must be so
excited and at the end you gots them you
say so that was cool right you know you
you know he would got to be storm troops
in there like what you got to be strong
true wasn't it huh and you go you know
Star Wars no and you're going you know
you know store well you know some
troopers they're like no and you go do
you know what any of this isn't like
no I mean like do you feel really stupid
they're like yes so they're gonna have a
surprise when these billboards turn up
in the Maldives for them Diego Luna
hamed
as essential to any good Star Wars film
is a good villain or a compelling iconic
villain Star Wars fans as director
chronic Ben Mendelsohn
so there is some important business
particularly for Felicity Jones our
felicity last year I had the incredibly
surreal experience of being made into a
Star Wars action figure
and today I would like to welcome you to
the club because goodness goodness
here is your gin are so action-figure
thank you very very much I feel very
privileged to have joined the Star Wars
doll universe this is actually the very
first toy being revealed from rogue one
it's not as good as mine but you know
it's great number I don't know she's got
a pretty cool Han Solo gun belt inspired
by Han Solo I'm so Felicity from what
I've heard about your character
she's been compared to incredible
heroines like Joan of Arc which of
course I love and fans also compare this
new hero to their favorite Star Wars
heroes as well how was gin unique or
different to other Star Wars characters
I feel there's one major difference
between jyn erso and other Star Wars
heroes ray and Luke and that main
difference would be that that Jin she's
not a character who's asking Who am I
and and where have I come from she she
very much we know that about her we know
where she's come from and that fact is
is what propels propels the story and
and it's the beginning of Jin's journey
to find out what her reason is and and
her her course and she's had a very full
life before we meet her unlike other
Star Wars heroes obviously um no hero
can go to lone Diego can you please tell
us a little bit about cassian definitely
hi everyone
just
I think I've been waiting for this night
for time this is actually what got me
into the project the chance to share
this energy it's fantastic so yes I play
Katherine under captain calendar and he
works for the rebellion for intelligence
and the team starts being just the two
of them Jane and casseon but as the
story continues the team grows and like
any team there's frictions there's
issues and his cassian who has to keep
them together and one of the most
important members of this team is a
droid an imperial toid that is
reprogrammed by their by the rebellion
and his name is k2s oh and he's probably
the best friend
Kasim has in in the rebellion or the
only one and I think that's the first
time we're hearing that information that
it's a Star Wars special for you was it
I hope I was allowed you were totally
right it's fine okay um of course no
Star Wars story could exist without a
droid and in rogue one we meet k2s oh
wait by Alan Tudyk Alan
Allen you are a man of many talents
you're an actor you're voiceover artists
and you've actually played a robot
before as well can you tell us a little
bit about what it's like being a droid
in a Star Wars film we were Jordan this
was great
did you get to meet him did you get to
meet Anthony Daniels my one was called
the force awakens
I met him at that party at the opening
night and I Stalin kid - I so I'm gonna
be the next Droid in his series roids I
guess and he said do you wear a suit Oh
CGI
and I heard a story about something
about you in the Maldives possibly with
a boat on a boat in the a go didn't go
to swim with you like to spend your time
the biggest shark cool and these spots
and the gorgeous and so I swam her
yeah good good getting pimples of plenty
from the Star Wars universe um there was
also something exciting that happened at
a tube station Gareth is this true oh
yeah I used to I actually my first job
ever in in television was just around
the corner from where we are right now
and they used to pass it every day and
go through the Docklands the DLR and all
these train station thing this is like
something from the future this like a
sci-fi movie if I ever get to do a
sci-fi film in my life I'm gonna I'm
gonna film it here and then I parked
that thought and then one day when we're
trying to figure out how to do these
really long shots they involve a lot of
running and building big massive sets
and we were trying to be clever about it
I was like ah let's just film at the
Docklands
it looks futuristic then I was like ha
ha ha yeah very funny anyway how we
gonna really do this and then eventually
the art department like got really
imaginative and we did this secret
mission where we went to Canary Wharf
one night and it was no one was allowed
to tell anyone because we didn't want
anyone finding out and so as soon as
that thing closed the midnight and you
saw these guys with suits getting the
last train and walking past as soon as
they're gone we all dived in we had four
hours they had to set dress the whole
thing bring all the stuff in they've
rehearsed it before and we shot the
scenes and we shot all the scenes then
we had to be out of there by 4:00 a.m.
and we were like we've got the last one
just in time and as we left everything
would disappeared and they open the
doors and all these guys in suits came
in and we like morning morning and
you're so desperate want to tell them as
you walk past morning morning morning we
just shot Star Wars like it was a
stormtrooper - tube stops away from here
I knew this might come up today so I
counted us for it's at 4:00 yeah okay
we'll start the pilgrimage now
I'm back to our amazing cast rizz
are your acting career has included
roles in acclaimed indie films like for
lions the Reluctant Fundamentalist
Nightcrawler and the new HBO show the
night off
what attracted you to this film why a
Star Wars movie um I thought just like
to kind of change your help it'd be good
to do a film that other people have seen
apart from just that one guy that was
shouting
thank you for your costume I mean who
doesn't want to do these films I mean
they attract the best talent across the
board and also Alan it's just an amazing
world to be a part of you know so ya
know I just really wanted to be a part
of it obviously I've seen kind of
Gareth's work and just found it super
exciting so and we know also that we
have a reprogrammed Imperial droid who
is I have noticed in photos of your
character Bodie he's wearing an imperial
patch so what's going on there yeah well
I can talk about its color little bit
yeah well you know bone in that bori
bori is a pilot and he works for the
empire you know to earn a living and
like you know people work at big
organizations they don't agree with
everything they do
we good
if maybe you don't have to get judging
please
maybe questioning yeah yeah exactly he's
kind of questioning things and that the
planet that he is the city that he is
from is actually an occupied planet and
it's the actions of the Empire and the
stuff that he's forced to be involved
with over there that kind of makes him
question his his career counselor and
bodis home is also where we meet Donnie
and Jang's characters and turret Gareth
can you tell us about Jed oh yeah
jealous I guess the easiest way to
explain is obviously our film takes
place in a time where there are
allegedly no Jedi remaining and and but
people still believe in the force and
they still have that that spirituality
and essentially Jed is like I guess like
the mecca of Star Wars in that people go
on pilgrimages and and and the problem
is right now is when the story begins is
the there it's an occupied territory by
the empire and we get sucked into a
story that involves these wonderful
people to the side here and two of the
most important characters we meet in
jeddah are turret and Bay's they become
crucial to the team and a played by
Donnie Yen and Jiang where
Johnny what can you tell us about chat I
just want to say hi everybody I'm Donnie
I play a blind warrior who lives in the
planet Jenna I can't see but I can feel
with my heart and believe in the
spiritual of the force and obviously me
and gentlemen is we have the baddest
fighter from Jenna and I mean Jan his
character base we are very good friends
and that's about the story of about the
town right that's it too much right
maybe maybe it's time for Jiang to tell
us about Bey's
so hear me he was a father and he'd be
believed of course mentally divorce but
my cracker done with the force at that
time but I protect all of them
nothing just to do very very big passion
what I do something better
maybe I have to be by my action
he's Baker I'm doing so I think you've
gotta leave it I think you've gotta
leave it that way
yeah a big gun it's a guy
forest we've learned a lot about yob
we've learned a lot about your
characters deeper connection in the Star
Wars galaxy
how does he connect to this band of
misfits I think we can definitely call
them misfits
good see what Sagar is a is a rebel
fighter he's been fighting for years
against the Imperial occupation
he's a guerrilla fighter he is uh he has
been a controlling a group of rebels
that are out to the extreme we're
talking about that that there's a series
of different rebel groups coming
together as an alliance and all of these
people are different parts of that I'm
uh
I'm leading my group which which which
by any means necessary they'll do what
he needs to do in order to save the
world
he was trained as a guerrilla fighter
and Lin he was trained and Saul was
originally revealed as an animated
character a character that originated
with George Lucas well yeah yeah I mean
Gareth introduced me to the character I
was amazing I went back and started to
look and see the series of Clone Wars
and really understand what was going on
with that
so that's how is it a good thing he's
been integrated in working with Chen and
everyone to to make things before thank
you Gareth for you as a filmmaker and as
a fan what was it like for you bringing
to life a character created by George
Lucas did you meet George Lucas did he
come on set or um well one Friday I got
a phone call of John Schwarz who's one
of the produce on the film here it goes
meme guys guess who's gonna visit on
Monday and I was like I don't know it's
like have a guess sarcastic when George
Lucas went yeah like [ __ ] and so spend
the whole weekend just crapping myself
about this and uh and was very surprised
because he is the nicest guy he's got an
amazing sense of humor and we were
showing him around all the stuff and
it's the honest I challenge anyone to
have a more surreal experience than
showing a Star Wars film to George Lucas
for the first time he's right up there
and and we we were and he'd start
criticizing stuff and you'd get really
nervous and I'll god oh god oh god
and then he'd make a joke at the end you
realize he's being sarcastic and there'd
be this massive relief but we were all
having heart attacks like he's got this
really like dry sense of humor which is
I'd normally love but I was I was like
riding this rollercoaster and and I just
want to say I want to take a moment to
say like none of this none of this would
be happening if it wasn't for George
Lucas the guy's a genius
there is a theme of passion fathers and
Star Wars films fathers identities and
their relationships with their children
maths we now have confirmation we now
have confirmation that your character
Gailen Ursa is Jin's father what else
can you tell us that's it no I honestly
it's if you know that's a lot of secrecy
around the whole thing for good reasons
and my character is a person of interest
a lot of things are revolving around him
so it would be like kind of a big
spoiler to say too much but can I say
that he's a he's a scientist and he at
one point invented something so
beautiful so fantastic that it might
change the universe that's all I can say
and then I can say I Minister Worcester
okay Star Wars fans I'm bringing him
back to the stage please welcome mr. Ben
Mendelsohn
I just had to take advantage of that
moment um welcome back to the stage
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be back and what was that about well I
would love to answer your questions but
I have been in communication with the
Emperor and the sizzle that we started
to see earlier is now back on board so
you can have me soliloquy or we can have
the sizzle okay so I've got to ask you I
think we want to know a little bit about
director cranek don't we yeah then what
can you tell them do you want to yes
that's quite correct so I've heard that
cranek is a different kind of imperial
villain right yes
he is he's an Australian kind we do
villainy very well he is smarter I think
than most of the most of his
predecessors he's more inventive he's
perhaps a little sexier than some of
them not quite as sexy as some of the
others
darling clangs that's all I've got okay
oh it was enough for me um didn't you do
something to Garrett's assistant people
to tell that to I wished him a very
happy birthday is what I did and I
believe he had a very very memorable
birthday indeed I yelled at the boy
yelled at him but it was under direction
from sir okay let's just leave that
there
yes I think so it was cruelty that was
invited it was necessary okay
um I don't think we can talk about Star
Wars villains without bringing up one
name in particular we do have
confirmation that Darth Vader
Gareth what can you say about that
Gareth can you give me a little hint at
ease about Darth Vader being in rogue
one I guess I gotta really I got a very
early Christmas present in right we
finished filming in December and I got
straight on the plane to New York to do
a voiceover recording with a gentleman
called James Earl Jones now I can't tell
you what role he plays in the film good
I don't want to give that away but
what's really funny is I went there with
I went there with likes matwood from
Skywalker Sound and we were doing yeah
and and and we're all being very
professional in the way the ADR works is
obviously got their back to you they're
watching the screen and they're doing
the lines and then they turn around and
ask if that was okay so every time you
do a line and I don't wanna give
anything away but there was one point
where and we were all like yes hi James
here this is great that you're doing
really well this thank you and then he
did this one line where he says the word
powwow and we just both looked at each
there and had this nerdgasm
we were like reduced to three-year-olds
and instantly he looked back and
recently went that was great James
you